Discovering that a partner has been unfaithful is one of the most painful experiences that a person can go through. It can shake your sense of trust, security, and even identity. Today we're going to talk with a psychologist who studies infidelity and commitment about why people cheat and what happens to relationships when they do. We'll talk about what the research says about infidelity. Is it increasing in the age of dating apps, social media, and chatbot companions? How does psychologists think about what constitutes? cheating? Does there have to be a physical element? Can relationships recover after one partner cheats? And how do psychologists help individuals and couples navigate what comes next after a betrayal?
发现伴侣不忠是人所能经历的最痛苦的体验之一。它会动摇你的信任感、安全感，甚至自我认同感。今天，我们将与一位研究不忠和承诺的心理学家探讨人们为何会出轨，以及出轨后关系会发生什么。我们将讨论研究对不忠的看法。在约会软件、社交媒体和聊天机器人伴侣盛行的时代，不忠行为是否在增加？心理学家如何看待什么是“出轨”？一定要有身体接触才算吗？伴侣一方出轨后，关系还能修复吗？心理学家如何帮助个人和伴侣在背叛发生后走出困境？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Galena Rhodes, a research professor of psychology and director of the Institute for Relationship Science at the University of Denver. Her research focuses on romantic relationships, commitment and relationship stability, as well as maternal mental health and relationship education programs. Dr. Rhodes is a licensed clinical psychologist and in addition to her research, she has a small private practice where she conducts individual and couples therapy. She recently spoke with APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology for an article on how psychologists
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天的嘉宾是加莱娜·罗兹（Galena Rhodes）博士，她是丹佛大学心理学研究教授，也是关系科学研究所所长。她的研究重点是浪漫关系、承诺和关系稳定性，以及孕产妇心理健康和关系教育项目。罗兹博士是一位持证临床心理学家，除了研究工作外，她还经营着一家小型私人诊所，进行个人和伴侣治疗。她最近接受了美国心理学会《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）杂志的采访，谈到了心理学家
help patients heal from infidelity. Dr. Rhodes, thank you for joining you for joining you. me today. Kim, thank you for having me. I'm glad to be here. Let's start with some context. How do you define infidelity and do psychologists have an agreed upon definition or do couples have to define that boundary for themselves? Well, I think the definition of infidelity is changing all the time. It's somewhat dynamic, right? Because as technology changes and the way people can connect with other people changes. I think it really is about the expectations that partners have for one another. And psychologists may be famous for not actually being able to agree on many definitions of many things. And I don't think there is a tried and true definition. I think the easiest
如何帮助患者从不忠的创伤中恢复。罗兹博士，感谢您今天能来参加节目。金，谢谢你的邀请，很高兴来到这里。让我们先从背景谈起。您如何定义不忠？心理学家对此有统一的定义吗？还是说伴侣必须自己划定界限？嗯，我认为不忠的定义一直在变化。它在某种程度上是动态的，对吧？因为随着技术的发展，人们建立联系的方式也在改变。我认为这实际上取决于伴侣之间对彼此的期望。心理学家可能以无法就许多事物的定义达成一致而闻名。我不认为有一个放之四海而皆准的定义。我认为最简单的
way to identify it is when one partner feels as though there has been a betrayal of trust and expectations that have been broken. So it's a kind of, you know it when you feel it. Right. Well said. Now, I'm old enough to remember when President Jimmy Carter created a brouhaha by telling Playboy magazine that he had looked at other women with lust and had committed adultery in his heart many times. Is that infidelity? And I should note, he and his wife Rosalind stayed together until the very end and they were always seen as very devoted to each other. But does that constantly? institute infidelity? Well, you know, today as we hear that, it sounds sort of quaint, doesn't it? That sounds sort of sweet hearing that. But I think it may have, right, in the way that he was describing that.
识别方式是，当一方感到信任受到背叛，且双方的期望被打破时。所以这是一种“当你感觉到时，你就知道”的情况。说得好。现在，我年纪够大，还记得吉米·卡特总统曾因告诉《花花公子》杂志他曾多次在心中对其他女性产生欲望并犯下通奸罪而引起轩然大波。那是不忠吗？我应该指出，他和妻子罗莎琳一直在一起直到最后，他们一直被视为对彼此非常忠诚。但这是否构成了不忠？嗯，你知道，今天当我们听到这些话时，觉得有点古怪，不是吗？听到这些话感觉有点甜蜜。但我认为，在他描述那种情况的方式中，可能确实如此。
He felt as though he was betraying his wife's trust in some way, that it crossed some boundary or expectation or agreement spoken or unspoken that they had between each other. And the fact that, you know, in the way that he said that, it was as if it was a confession, right? And we make confessions like that if we know we've done something that might hurt someone else. Right. Although not usually to Playboy magazine. Excellent point. These days, a lot of people talk about having a work husband or a work wife, right? Somebody at their job with whom they have a really close relationship. Is that a form of cheating? I like that question a lot because it does seem like that is a common phrase we hear these days that indicates some kind of close relationship.
他觉得自己在某种程度上背叛了妻子的信任，跨越了他们之间某种明示或暗示的界限、期望或协议。而且事实上，他那样说的方式，就好像这是一种忏悔，对吧？如果我们知道自己做了可能伤害别人的事，我们就会做出这样的忏悔。没错。虽然通常不会对《花花公子》杂志说。观点极佳。如今，很多人谈论拥有“职场丈夫”或“职场妻子”，对吧？就是工作中关系非常亲密的人。这是一种出轨吗？我很喜欢这个问题，因为这似乎是我们现在常听到的一个短语，用来指代某种亲密关系。
I think when people say that, what they typically mean is that they have a very close, collaborative working relationship with someone, that they can kind of speak one another's language, finish one another's sentences, that there's a companionship in that. But we don't always know what that means, right? And I think if someone's saying that, it may be that to the other partner, it is clear what that means, but I think it would warrant some kind of conversation around what are the expectations for that relationship. What does that mean to you to say you have a work husband, a work wife? And does it include some kind of emotional or physical intimacy that does cross a line for the true primary relationship? I want to see if we can talk. about some stats, if there are any, how common is infidelity? Is it possible to get any kind of good survey data on this question? You know, it's related to your first question. How do we define infidelity? Right. So if we ask, have you cheated on your spouse? Historically, we saw levels
我认为当人们这样说时，他们通常是指与某人有非常密切的协作工作关系，他们可以理解对方的语言，接上对方的话茬，从中获得陪伴感。但我们并不总是知道这意味着什么，对吧？我认为如果有人这么说，对另一半来说可能很清楚这意味着什么，但我认为这值得就该关系的期望进行一番对话。说你有“职场丈夫”或“职场妻子”对你来说意味着什么？它是否包含某种跨越了真正主要关系底线的精神或身体亲密关系？我想看看我们是否能谈谈
around 10 to 20 percent of married spouses reporting that they had cheated. And over time, we saw a rise in women's cheating infidelity over time, and men sort of stayed at a similar level. But because it's so hard to define, you could ask, have you ever had sex with someone other than your spouse? Right. You could ask, have you ever cheated on your spouse? And you could get wildly different answers. You could ask the spouse, right? Has your spouse ever cheated on you?
一些统计数据，如果有的话，不忠有多普遍？关于这个问题，有可能获得任何好的调查数据吗？你知道，这与你的第一个问题有关。我们如何定义不忠？对吧。所以如果我们问：“你曾背叛过你的配偶吗？”从历史上看，我们看到大约 10% 到 20% 的已婚配偶报告说他们曾有过不忠行为。随着时间的推移，我们看到女性的不忠行为有所增加，而男性的比例则保持在相似水平。但因为定义太难了，你可以问：“你曾与配偶以外的人发生过性关系吗？”对吧。你可以问：“你曾背叛过你的配偶吗？”你会得到截然不同的答案。你可以问配偶，对吧？“你的配偶曾背叛过你吗？”
and you might get a different answer in one direction or the other, whether that's related to knowledge of the infidelity or the definition of infidelity. So we do know that it happens. And we do know that oftentimes, I think the data from national survey from the early 2000 showed that about half of those couples who were married then ended in divorce. But that number is maybe not as high as you would think in some ways, right? that it is not an absolute.
你可能会得到一个方向或另一个方向的不同答案，这取决于是否知晓不忠行为，或者对不忠的定义。所以我们确实知道这种情况会发生。我们也确实知道，我认为 21 世纪初的全国调查数据显示，当时约有一半的已婚夫妇最终离婚了。但这个数字在某些方面可能并不像你想象的那么高，对吧？它不是绝对的。
If there's infidelity, it's going to lead to divorce. Are there demographic differences? I mean, you mentioned that the prevalence among women seems to be increasing. Do people of, say, higher socioeconomic status cheat more than those at the lower end of the scale? Are there any other differences that we know of? I don't think so. Not that are measured in reliable ways. And it may be in part related to the definition.
如果有不忠行为，就一定会导致离婚。有人口统计学上的差异吗？我的意思是，你提到女性的普遍率似乎在增加。社会经济地位较高的人比处于较低阶层的人更容易出轨吗？我们知道还有其他差异吗？我不这么认为。没有以可靠方式测量出来的差异。这可能在一定程度上与定义有关。
and that it is something that is so secretive that people don't really want to report, even if they believe their answers will be kept confidential or anonymous. So we don't see big differences that we can regularly see over time or that seem to be reliable. So women and men cheat at similar rates? You know, I haven't seen national data recently. I would bet that women's rates are still a little lower, but they had been climbing up closer to where men's rates were. And it's also important to recognize, you know, most of the research that's been conducted around infidelity has been with married couples. But so many people are in significant relationships today, whether it's before marriage or as an alternative to marriage that, you know,
而且这是一件非常隐秘的事情，即使人们相信他们的回答会被保密或匿名，他们也不太愿意报告。所以我们没有看到我们可以长期观察到的、或看起来可靠的巨大差异。所以男女出轨率相似？你知道，我最近没有看到全国性的数据。我敢打赌女性的比例仍然略低，但她们一直在攀升，接近男性的比例。同样重要的是要认识到，你知道，大多数关于不忠的研究都是针对已婚夫妇进行的。但今天有很多人处于重要的关系中，无论是在婚前还是作为婚姻的替代选择，你知道，
are symbolized by a strong commitment to one another. And we know even less about non-married relationships and what infidelity might look like in them or if there are differences between married and non-married relationships around infidelity. And it certainly doesn't mean that it hurts any less if it's in a non-married relationship. All right. Well, there's an area of research for someone's PhD. Yeah, that's right. I want to talk about how people react to discovering infidelity? Do women and men react differently? Because I've read that heterosexual men are more distressed when their partners have a sexual affair and that heterosexual women are more distressed by emotional cheating. Is that borne out by any research? It is. And it doesn't mean that the other type
都以对彼此的强烈承诺为象征。我们对非婚姻关系了解得更少，不知道不忠在其中可能是什么样子，或者在不忠问题上，婚姻关系和非婚姻关系之间是否存在差异。而且这当然不意味着如果发生在非婚姻关系中，伤害就会减轻。好吧，这确实是一个适合某人攻读博士学位的研究领域。是的，没错。我想谈谈人们在发现不忠后的反应？男女反应不同吗？因为我读到过，异性恋男性在伴侣发生性出轨时更痛苦，而异性恋女性对精神出轨更痛苦。这有任何研究支持吗？确实有。但这并不意味着另一种类型
for either men or women in opposite sex relationships isn't important. You know, if you're a man, you're welcome to have a physical relationship, it won't bother your wife or vice versa. But I think what is important in that is recognizing that there are some differences between men and women and what may constitute a closer emotional relationship or more intimate relationship and the role of physical versus emotional closeness may be important in different ways to men and women. Do you believe have you seen research showing that cheating has increased or not in this era of dating apps and social media? I think if we broaden the definition of cheating, right? If cheating today includes having a relationship with someone that could be a close relationship,
对于异性关系中的男性或女性来说就不重要。你知道，如果你是一个男人，你欢迎有身体关系，这不会困扰你的妻子，反之亦然。但我认为重要的是要认识到，男性和女性在什么可能构成更亲密的精神关系或更亲密的关系方面存在一些差异，身体亲密与精神亲密的作用对男性和女性来说可能以不同的方式很重要。你是否相信，或者你是否见过研究表明，在这个约会软件和社交媒体时代，出轨行为有所增加？我认为如果我们扩大出轨的定义，对吧？如果今天的出轨包括与某人建立一种可能是亲密的关系，
even though you don't see them in person or see them often, yes, we have the opportunity to day to connect with many, many more people than in prior generations, right? And that could be people that you're meeting. You met at a conference and continue to have some kind of, you know, relationship with via social media or texting or phone calls, right? But don't see that person. It could be an old flame, right? We stay connected to X's. much more today than what was ever possible, right? You can Google, you can be friends on Facebook, you can connect in a multitude of ways with people that you may have known in your past, you may have had a relationship with in your past, or that you may have met only once or not even at all,
即使你没有亲自见到他们或不经常见到他们，是的，我们今天有机会与比前几代人多得多的人建立联系，对吧？这可能是你在会议上遇到的人，并通过社交媒体、短信或电话继续保持某种关系，对吧？但并没有见过那个人。这可能是旧情人，对吧？我们今天与前任保持联系的可能性比以往任何时候都要大，对吧？你可以谷歌搜索，你可以在 Facebook 上成为好友，你可以通过多种方式与你过去可能认识的人、你过去可能与之有过关系的人，或者你可能只见过一次甚至根本没见过的人建立联系，
but met online in some way. And those kinds of relationships certainly can hurt the other person and feel like a betrayal. I think the flip side of that is that technology also means that there are some additional checks and balances in that, right? That if you're trying to hide something that's happening online, it's possible. But there's also more eyes on those relationships, right? It's easier to know where your partner is because of Find My and other apps that, you know, you may share and track one another on. So in some ways, I think that's related to the definition,
但在网上以某种方式相遇。这些关系当然会伤害另一个人，并让人感觉是一种背叛。我认为其反面是，技术也意味着其中有一些额外的制衡，对吧？如果你试图隐藏网上发生的事情，是有可能的。但这些关系也有更多双眼睛盯着，对吧？因为“查找我的朋友”（Find My）和其他你可能共享并追踪彼此位置的应用程序，更容易知道你的伴侣在哪里。所以在某些方面，我认为这与定义有关，
sort of changing and being more about, as you said, if it feels like it, it likely is infidelity. But I do think there are some ways that there is a higher level of monitoring one another that can build both trust in some ways and a sense of concern in some other ways. I want to talk a little bit about why we think people, cheat. I mean, there have to be scores of reasons why people are unfaithful, but what does the research tell us? Is it mostly because of relationship dissatisfaction or boredom or maybe a desire to get back at a partner you're angry at? And are there warning flags that might tell us that someone is highly likely to cheat? I think all of those reasons that you just gave are reasons that
某种程度上在改变，更多地是关于，正如你所说的，如果感觉像，那很可能就是不忠。但我确实认为，在某种程度上，人们对彼此的监控水平更高，这既可以在某些方面建立信任，也可以在其他方面产生担忧。我想谈谈为什么我们认为人们会出轨。我的意思是，人们不忠的原因一定有很多，但研究告诉我们什么？主要是因为对关系不满或无聊，或者可能是想报复让你生气的伴侣？有没有什么警示信号可以告诉我们某人极有可能出轨？我认为你刚才提到的所有原因都是
someone may wind up cheating in a relationship. But oftentimes it's really more about the availability of another partner. And that's a little harder to explain in some ways, right, that in fact, it's not just dissatisfied people who cheat in their marriages or in their relationships. It may be that someone else comes along that they are really taken by or that they wind up spending a lot of time with and it slowly develops over time and it may not actually be reflective of being deeply unhappy in their relationship. Now, I will say oftentimes in therapy, if they're coming to therapy, that winds up being part of the narrative because we're trying to explain our own behavior to ourselves in some way. Right. So, well, if I'm cheating, I must be deeply unhappy or angry
某人在一段关系中最终出轨的原因。但通常这更多是关于是否有其他伴侣可供选择。这在某些方面有点难解释，对吧？事实上，不仅仅是不满的人会在婚姻或关系中出轨。可能是出现了另一个人，他们真的被吸引了，或者他们最终花了很多时间在一起，它随着时间的推移慢慢发展，这实际上可能并不反映他们在关系中深感不快乐。现在，我要说的是，在治疗中，如果他们来接受治疗，这往往会成为叙事的一部分，因为我们试图以某种方式向自己解释自己的行为。对吧。所以，“好吧，如果我在出轨，我一定是对我的配偶深感不快乐或愤怒。”
at my spouse. I just think we sort of create that narrative sometimes to justify the behavior when it was really more happenstance that someone wound up cheating. So the opportunity presented itself and it was just too tantalizing. That's right. Does the reason behind an affair influence whether couples are able to recover and are there some types of betrayals that are harder to move past than others? It not only matters for the depth of the betrayal, but it matters in part for the person who is participating in the affair, the one who is cheating. If they are very strongly connected to this person, it's going to be harder for them to end the affair to close that relationship and to recover from the breakup and the grief that they may feel when that affair ends and then be able to
我只是认为我们有时会编造这种叙事来为这种行为辩护，而实际上这更多是偶然，有人最终出轨了。所以机会出现了，而且太诱人了。没错。出轨背后的原因是否会影响伴侣能否恢复？有些类型的背叛是否比其他类型更难克服？这不仅对背叛的深度很重要，而且在一定程度上对参与出轨的人，即出轨的那个人也很重要。如果他们与这个人联系非常紧密，他们将很难结束这段关系，很难从分手和出轨结束后可能感受到的悲伤中恢复过来，然后能够
reconnect well with their primary partner. So what we sometimes see in that is if the motivation or the reason or I think it may be more related to the strength or the depth of the connection and the affair, if it's very hard for someone to end, that not only is going to hurt the primary partner more, but it may be that it takes longer for the person participating in the affair to get over it and move on, that there's some real pain that they may be experiencing in that,
与他们的主要伴侣重新建立良好的联系。所以我们有时看到的是，如果动机或原因，或者我认为这可能更多地与出轨中联系的强度或深度有关，如果某人很难结束，这不仅会更伤害主要伴侣，而且参与出轨的人可能需要更长时间才能走出来并继续前进，他们可能会经历一些真正的痛苦，
which their partner, primary partner, is not ever going to understand, right? That's going to be really hard for someone who's been hurt by an affair to understand that the participating partner is also going through some pain and ending the affair. Right. Yes. It'd be pretty hard to say, gee, I feel bad for you. Exactly. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about whether psychologists can predict who's likely to cheat and whether there are characteristics or relationship patterns that make infidelity more likely. Now, can you as a psychologist
这是他们的主要伴侣永远无法理解的，对吧？对于一个被出轨伤害的人来说，要理解参与的一方在结束出轨时也会经历痛苦，这真的很难。没错。是的。说“哎呀，我为你感到难过”会非常困难。完全正确。我们要休息一下。回来后，我们将讨论心理学家是否能预测谁可能出轨，以及是否存在使不忠更有可能发生的特征或关系模式。现在，作为一名心理学家，你能
predict who's likely to cheat? Are there characteristics or relationship patterns that make infidelity more likely? Not well, but isn't this a thing about psychology? So much of our work is trying to predict human behavior and we explain very little in outcomes in human behavior. I will say one thing that does precede infidelity is an increase in what psychologists, the social psychologists call alternative monitoring, how much someone is looking at the availability of other partners or their awareness of other people who they may have some connection with, have some attraction to. So we do see that there is an increase in that concept of alternative monitoring before infidelity happens. And we do see that there is an increase in that concept of alternative monitoring before infidelity
预测谁可能出轨吗？是否存在使不忠更有可能发生的特征或关系模式？预测得并不好，但这不就是心理学的问题吗？我们的大部分工作都是试图预测人类行为，而我们对人类行为结果的解释却很少。我会说，在不忠之前确实发生的一件事是心理学家、社会心理学家所说的“替代方案监控”的增加，即某人对其他伴侣的可获得性的关注程度，或者他们对可能与之有某种联系、有某种吸引力的其他人的意识。所以我们确实看到，在不忠发生之前，这种“替代方案监控”的概念有所增加。我们确实看到，在不忠发生之前，这种“替代方案监控”的概念有所增加。
happens. And we think of that as a type of commitment. If you're highly dedicated, committed to your partner, you're just less likely to be thinking about and looking around at other people, essentially. So the more, you know, we might see that in ourselves, right? We could do a self-assessment, you know, how much am I kind of just paying attention to how much I like my friend's partner or like this person at work or, huh, that person seems really attractive. You know, how much sort of headspace is that taking up is one tiny predictor of infidelity? What about people who have serial relationships that keep breaking up because the other person cheated? Are there characteristics of those people who are more likely to get involved again with cheaters? It's sort of like people who
我们认为这是一种承诺类型。如果你对你的伴侣高度投入、忠诚，你基本上就不太可能去想和关注其他人。所以，你知道，我们可能会在自己身上看到这一点，对吧？我们可以做一个自我评估，你知道，我有多关注我有多喜欢我朋友的伴侣，或者喜欢这个在工作中的人，或者，嗯，那个人看起来真的很吸引人。你知道，这占据了多少脑力空间，是预测不忠的一个微小指标。那么那些有连续关系，因为对方出轨而不断分手的人呢？那些更有可能再次与出轨者纠缠在一起的人有什么特征吗？这有点像那些
have abusive relationships will connect with abusers. Does the same thing happen with cheaters? It does. In fact, some of our work shows just that, that if someone cheated in their last relationship, they're more likely to cheat in their next relationship. This was among unmarried couples. Similarly, if a person was cheated on in their last relationship, they're more likely to be cheated on in their next relationship. And I think part of that second question around, you know, if you were cheated on before or you're more likely to be cheated on again, it's really tragic that that may be the case, right?
有虐待关系的人会与施虐者建立联系。出轨者身上也会发生同样的情况吗？确实会。事实上，我们的一些研究表明正是如此，如果某人在上一段关系中出轨，他们在下一段关系中出轨的可能性就更大。这是在未婚夫妇中进行的。同样，如果一个人在上一段关系中被出轨，他们在下一段关系中被出轨的可能性也更大。我认为关于第二个问题的部分，你知道，如果你以前被出轨过，你是否更有可能再次被出轨，这真的很悲惨，对吧？
And I think it may be related to some internal kind of models around relationships and whether people are able to identify healthy, safe partners. for themselves, whether they may wind up staying in relationships, past a point where other people may have turned back and did the relationship. So they might find themselves either not being able to identify partners well. Maybe in some cases, even seeking out partners who kind of seem similar, right? It may feel natural. It may feel normal to them to be able to be with someone who has some of those traits, even when it is not really healthy. So there may be some kind of internal reasons why people could find themselves with similar kinds of people.
我认为这可能与关于关系的某种内部模型有关，以及人们是否能够为自己识别健康、安全的伴侣。他们是否最终会留在关系中，超过了其他人可能已经回头并结束关系的那个点。所以他们可能会发现自己要么无法很好地识别伴侣。也许在某些情况下，甚至会寻找看起来相似的伴侣，对吧？这可能感觉很自然。对他们来说，能够与具有这些特质的人在一起可能感觉很正常，即使这并不真正健康。所以人们可能会因为某种内部原因而发现自己与相似的人在一起。
And then this part about staying with people, part of what happens, I think, in relationships, whether it's around cheating or other kinds of stay and go ambiguous behavior or ambivalent commitment, is that if you're in a relationship with someone who has not as committed as you are, part of what can happen is that you lose your own ability to evaluate whether this is a good partner for me. Because it becomes about trying to win the validation, the commitment, the attachment from the other person, rather than being able to really from a more kind of in a more secure way, evaluate whether this person is treating me the way I deserve to be treated, whether I truly feel connected and loved by this person.
然后关于留在人们身边的那部分，我认为在关系中发生的事情，无论是关于出轨还是其他类型的“留还是走”的模棱两可的行为或矛盾的承诺，是如果你与一个不像你那么投入的人建立关系，可能发生的一部分事情是你失去了自己评估这是否是一个好伴侣的能力。因为这变成了试图赢得对方的认可、承诺、依恋，而不是能够以一种更安全的方式，真正评估这个人是否以我应得的方式对待我，我是否真的感到与这个人有联系并被爱。
So I think there are some processes that may be hard to undo for people when they've experienced some of those negative kinds of behaviors and experiences in relationships. Speaking of Psychology did an episode earlier this year on chatbot relationships, and there's been a lot of reporting in the mainstream media on people having emotionally intimate relationships with chatbots. Are you encountering this in your practice? And would you think of it as cheating? How do you approach it with couples?
所以我认为当人们在关系中经历了一些负面行为和经历时，有一些过程可能很难逆转。《心理学谈话》今年早些时候做了一期关于聊天机器人关系的节目，主流媒体上有很多关于人们与聊天机器人建立情感亲密关系的报道。你在你的实践中遇到过这种情况吗？你会认为这是出轨吗？你如何与伴侣探讨这个问题？
You know, I think this is so interesting to think about what it means, really, whether it's cheating or not, to have a relationship, an AI or chatbot relationship. And as a psychologist, I really believe in true human connection. And so it really throws me off thinking about what it means to have potentially meaningful relationship with a non-human computer AI person, identity. Thing? Yeah. Yeah. And there may, there could be some benefits.
你知道，我认为思考这意味着什么真的很有趣，无论是与人工智能或聊天机器人建立关系是否是出轨。作为一名心理学家，我真的相信真正的人际联系。所以，思考与非人类的计算机人工智能人、身份、事物建立潜在的有意义的关系意味着什么，真的让我感到困惑。是啊。是啊。而且可能，可能会有一些好处。
I'm open to the idea that you could learn some good things in those relationships. relationships, perhaps. But I think it comes down to it's going to feel like betrayal to someone else. If you're sharing parts of yourself that we typically think of are really only meant for your partner, it will hurt the other person. Right. And so if you're having an in-depth relationship, whether it has some sexual overtones or not, that kind of relationship, may mean, likely means, I think, that you are missing out on a true connection with your partner and that your partner will likely be hurt by that, that you're sharing parts of yourself that are typically reserved for that primary relationship. And chatbots tend to affirm what you want them to say. I mean, the thing is, maybe you're having some tension with your partner. You go to a chatbot, which will always say, oh, you're all right, you're right.
我对在这些关系中可以学到一些好东西的想法持开放态度，也许吧。但我认为归根结底，这会让别人感到背叛。如果你分享了我们通常认为只属于你伴侣的那部分自我，这会伤害另一个人。没错。所以如果你正在进行一段深入的关系，无论它是否带有某种性色彩，那种关系可能意味着，我认为很可能意味着，你错过了与伴侣的真正联系，而且你的伴侣很可能会因此受到伤害，因为你分享了通常只保留给那种主要关系的自我部分。而且聊天机器人倾向于肯定你想让他们说的话。我的意思是，问题是，也许你和你的伴侣之间有一些紧张关系。你去找聊天机器人，它总是会说，哦，你是对的，你是对的。
You know, what you did was right, what she did was wrong. Exactly. You work with couples in your practice. What is your approach? I mean, how do you deal with people who come to you because there has been infidelity in the relationship? So when I work with a couple who has had infidelity in therapy, I use a model that was developed by colleagues of mine, Christy Gordon, Don Bacombe, and Doug Snyder. And there are three stages of that treatment approach. It includes the impact stage, or I kind of think of that as containing the damage and the affair.
你知道，你做的是对的，她做的是错的。完全正确。你在你的实践中与伴侣合作。你的方法是什么？我的意思是，你如何处理因为关系中出现不忠而找你的人？所以当我与有过不忠经历的伴侣进行治疗时，我使用了一种由我的同事克里斯蒂·戈登（Christy Gordon）、唐·巴科姆（Don Baucom）和道格·斯奈德（Doug Snyder）开发的方法。这种治疗方法有三个阶段。它包括影响阶段，或者我倾向于认为这是控制损害和出轨影响的阶段。
Think about who you're going to talk to about the affair, if anyone, right, so that you're not telling your mother and then your mother's telling her friends and this is getting more and more out of control, right? But think about what do you need as a couple to get support that you need, but also be sure that, you know, you're not totally erratic in how you're. you're responding to the news of the affair. The second stage is really understanding why the affair happened. So getting at some of those things you and I have talked about today around motivations, access to another partner, what it meant to the participating partner, what it feels like to the injured partner, the person who was hurt by the affair, of really understanding it.
考虑一下你要和谁谈论出轨，如果有的话，对吧，这样你就不会告诉你的母亲，然后你的母亲又告诉她的朋友，这就会变得越来越失控，对吧？但要考虑作为伴侣，你需要什么来获得所需的支持，同时也要确保，你知道，你在应对出轨消息时不会完全反复无常。第二阶段是真正理解出轨发生的原因。所以要触及你我今天谈到的关于动机、接触其他伴侣、这对参与的一方意味着什么、对受伤的一方（即被出轨伤害的人）感觉如何，真正理解它。
So that phase can be really difficult for couples to move through because they've got to talk about the affair, the impact it had, what was happening in the relationship that they may need to change if they decide to move forward together that kind of allowed the affair to happen.
所以这个阶段对伴侣来说可能真的很难度过，因为他们必须谈论出轨、它产生的影响、如果他们决定一起前进，他们可能需要改变关系中允许出轨发生的那些方面。
And then the third stage is really about what do we do next to move on? For some couples, that means ending the relationship, but they've done the work to process it well and understand that together, which will make their next relationship experiences better. Or if they're going on to co-parent together, it'll make their new relationship, coparenting relationship better. For many couples, it means not allowing the affair to control their lives and their relationship anymore and really thinking about what do we want for our new relationship? It's going to look different for many different reasons.
然后第三阶段是关于我们接下来该做什么才能继续前进？对于一些伴侣来说，这意味着结束这段关系，但他们已经完成了处理它的工作，并一起理解了它，这将使他们下一段关系的体验更好。或者如果他们继续共同抚养孩子，这将使他们新的共同抚养关系更好。对于许多伴侣来说，这意味着不再让出轨控制他们的生活和关系，并真正思考我们想要什么样的新关系？由于许多不同的原因，它看起来会不同。
We want it to look different. We want to make sure this doesn't happen again. We want to make sure it's fulfilling to both of us. So it gives a couple an opportunity to really redefine their relationship and set new expectations around communication, around talking with other people, all of those components, and really make decisions together, which they may not have done for many years, if ever.
我们希望它看起来不同。我们想确保这种情况不会再次发生。我们想确保它对我们双方来说都是充实的。所以它给了伴侣一个机会，真正重新定义他们的关系，并围绕沟通、与其他人交谈等所有这些组成部分设定新的期望，并真正一起做出决定，这可能是他们多年来甚至从未做过的。
What I like about this model is that it also has the overlay of thinking about an affair as trauma. And that's part of what we often see for the person who's been hurt by the affair, is that they have some traumatic responses to it. It might mean not driving by the hotel that you know your partner met the affair partner at, right? It might mean a lot of checking behavior, right? I need to check his phone.
我喜欢这种模式的一点是，它还将出轨视为创伤。这也是我们经常在被出轨伤害的人身上看到的一部分，即他们对此有一些创伤反应。这可能意味着不去开车经过你知道你的伴侣与出轨对象见面的酒店，对吧？这可能意味着大量的检查行为，对吧？我需要检查他的手机。
I need to know where she is at every moment. Some of that, I often say, we're just going to do that. We're going to decide to do that for a short period of time. Because in some ways those behaviors can build trust, right? but nobody wants that long term in a relationship. But I think it's a nice way to think about how hurtful it is and that we need reassurance. We're going to go through some waves of, you know, feeling really off because of an affair. And I really like that this model gives us a clear way to progress through treatment after an affair.
我需要时刻知道她在哪里。其中一些，我经常说，我们只是要这样做。我们决定在短时间内这样做。因为在某些方面，这些行为可以建立信任，对吧？但没有人希望在关系中长期这样。但我认为这是一种很好的方式来思考它有多么伤人，我们需要安慰。因为出轨，我们会经历一些感觉非常糟糕的波动。我真的很喜欢这种模式给了我们一种在出轨后进行治疗的清晰进展方式。
So I want to close by just asking you what you're working on now. I mean, what are the big questions that you're trying to answer at the moment? Well, somewhat related to what you were asking about in terms of chatbots, AI, robots. I'm really interested in how people are using AI today to learn about relationships. And there may be some things that people are looking for in terms of advice. answering, should I stay with this partner who's treating me like this or I feel this way? What do you think about this? And there may be some concerns to have about AI and what that means for gaining relationship advice or education. But I think there are also some ways that AI can help
所以我想最后问问你现在在做什么。我的意思是，你目前试图回答的重大问题是什么？嗯，与你刚才问的关于聊天机器人、人工智能、机器人的问题有些相关。我真的很感兴趣人们今天如何使用人工智能来了解关系。人们在寻求建议方面可能会寻找一些东西。回答，“我应该和这个这样对待我的伴侣在一起吗？”或者“我有这种感觉，你怎么看？”关于人工智能以及这对获得关系建议或教育意味着什么，可能会有一些担忧。但我认为人工智能也可以在某些方面帮助
elevate our conversations around relationships and support people in making decisions that are wise around relationships and what's best for them. So I'm excited to learn more about that and see how it evolves over time. So that's one of the projects that I'm really interested in today. All right. Well, I want to thank you so much for joining me. This has been very interesting and I'm sure helpful to some of our listeners. I'm glad.
提升我们关于关系的对话，并支持人们做出关于关系的明智决定，以及什么对他们最好。所以我很兴奋能更多地了解这一点，看看它随着时间的推移如何演变。所以这是我今天非常感兴趣的项目之一。好吧。嗯，我要非常感谢你加入我。这非常有趣，我相信对我们的一些听众很有帮助。我很高兴。
Kim, thanks very much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at Speaking of Psychology. or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
金，非常感谢你的邀请。你可以在我们的网站 Speaking of Psychology 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请关注我们并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。